an diesem entscheidenden tag denn heute
findet der lockdown gipfel mit angela
merkel und den ministerpräsidenten statt
mein name ist nele wirtz machen wir
wollen jetzt in dieser sendung natürlich
vor allem darüber sprechen denn das wort
login steht zwar nicht in den papieren
trotzdem sind es knallhart maßnahmen die
angela merkel jetzt fordert ab 13 uhr
diskutiert die ministerpräsidenten
gemeinsam mit angela merkel in der video
konferenz um bild liegt der beschluss
bereits vor in dem es jetzt also zu
immer mehr einschränkungen in unserem
öffentlichen leben kommen soll
und bei mir im studio ist jetzt paul
ronzheimer unser bc denn wir wollen
etwas auf diese beschlüsse schauen denn
paul wir haben noch von einem lok dann
leid gesprochen in letzter zeit jetzt wo
wir den entwurf haben muss man sagen
dass wortlaut trifft eigentlich
überhaupt nicht mehr zu ich denke jetzt
ist genau das was hier was sich in den
händen hält das ist der beschluss der
gestern getroffen wurde und kanzler man
muss klar sagen das ist das was angela
merkel will das ist noch nicht
besprochen mit den koalitionspartnern
und schon gar nicht mit allen
ministerpräsidenten
aber was wir hier sehen was hier stehen
die vorbereitung und die
telefonkonferenz der bundeskanzlerin mit
den regierungschefin und regierungschefs
der länder am 28 oktober 2020 das ist
die überschrift in diesem papier das duo
darüber entscheidet was deutschland noch
darf so kann man es nennen
und es ist genau das was bild vor zwei
tagen berichtet hat lok downlight leib
deshalb weil schulen offen bleiben
sollen und kitas aber das ist mehr oder
weniger auch so ein bisschen das einzige
was dieses papier von dem unterscheidet
was wir im frühjahr erlebt haben also
alles was spaß macht soll nach willen
der kanzlerin nicht gemacht werden
restaurants bars ist soll bei den
sporteinrichtungen einschränkungen geben
kinos der weitere unterschied ist
friseure sollen offen bleiben das ist
ein weiterer unterschied zum frühjahr
aber ansonsten du hast es angesprochen
absolute knallhart maßnahmen der
kanzlerin und die große frage ist jetzt
geht das papier was uns vorliegt dieses
papier tatsächlich so durch oder gibt es
widerstand und von diesem widerstand
höre ich bereits in diesen minuten höher
aus spd kreisen wo es nicht so
ausgemacht ist dass man die restaurants
komplett dichtmachen will und
insbesondere einzelne
ministerpräsidenten sagen offenbar
bereits so gehen sie nicht mit wir
wollen jetzt einmal bei uns liegt das
papier vor das gerade gesagt dass etwas
schritt für schritt durch gehen denn es
natürlich viele themen die uns alle sehr
interessieren vor allem kontakt
beschränkungen ein ganz großes thema was
ist da jetzt also die maßnahme die sich
zumindest die kanzlerin wünscht also
soll eine erhebliche reduzierung der
kontakte in der bevölkerung geben
man soll sich nur noch mit iks personen
in den eigenen vier wänden aufhalten
also es geht sozusagen darum dass man
nur noch mit den angehörigen in den
eigenen haushalt sein darf da steht dann
auch verstöße werden sanktioniert hatte
ich es hier auch wieder die frage wie um
himmels willen will man das
sanktionieren und vor allem wie will man
das kontrollieren ja ich meine wir
können ja nicht polizistin wurde oder
ordnungshüter vor jede wohnung schicken
und einmal kontrollieren
mit wem man da jetzt dort zu hause sitzt
also die große frage ist auch bei all
diesen maßnahmen wie wird das wieder
sanktioniert das sind die kontakte
beschränken dass gerade gesagt gute
nachricht wenn man das überhaupt hat
schulen und kitas sollen geöffnet
bleiben das wurde jetzt mehrfach betont
dass das eine hohe priorität hat anders
sieht es dann aber mit dem tourismus aus
der da auch angesprochen wird
man muss endlich sagen gibt es jetzt
laut diesem entwurf dann eigentlich gar
nicht mehr genau es soll dazu kommen was
die kanzlerin eben seit tagen und wochen
sagt kontakte beschränken kontakte
beschränken kontakte beschränken und nur
in anführungszeichen das was wirklich
notwendig ist so laufen bleiben aus
ihrer sicht dass in schulen und kitas
weil da steckt natürlich hinter dass man
große sorgen hat wenn man das jetzt auch
wieder dicht macht oder nicht machen
sollte
das ist dann schwierig wird hier sehen
wir die dinge die zum tourismus geplant
sind also übernachtungs gebote in
deutschland werden massiv beschränkt nun
notwendige und ausdrücklich nicht
touristische übernachtungen sollen
erlaubt bleiben auch hier die frage wie
wird das überprüft es kann das sein wie
im frühjahr dass man zum beispiel im
hotel ein ein papier eine bestätigung
des arbeitgebers vorzeigen muss oder
dass man zum beispiel
von dem auftraggeber für den mann
arbeitet vorweisen muss dass man
tatsächlich aus betrieblichen gründen
hier ist aber das ist alles etwas was
massiv an den für das früher erinnert an
früher erinnert vor allem weil wir uns
jetzt im sommer wieder daran gewöhnt
haben auch relativ viel freizeit wieder
gestalten zu können wie wir das wollen
auch da muss man eigentlich sagen mir
ist in dieser liste die wir hier auch
sehen nichts mehr aufgefallen was ich
eigentlich noch darf was sozusagen spaß
macht in meiner freizeit ist es wirklich
alles geschlossen wenn es nach merkel
geht ja ich weiß nicht wie gerne die
sonst zum friseur gehen
das ist zumindest das einzige mehr oder
weniger was das von früher unterscheidet
also theater opern und konzerthäuser
sollen dicht gemacht werden spiel
heimkinos freizeitparks fitnessstudios
sportanlagen schwimmbäder bordelle alles
geschlossen alle
unterhaltungsveranstaltungen sollen
untersagt werden hier prophezeie ich
auch erheblichen diskussionsbedarf
zwischen den ministerpräsidenten also
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
einfach so abgezeichnet wird aber das
ist natürlich auch ein politischer kampf
kanzlerin merkel hat fast genau vor zwei
wochen gesagt es reicht nicht aus was
wir beschlossen haben
wir müssen härter zuschlagen wir müssen
eine härtere maßnahmen sonst sitzen wir
in zwei wochen wieder
das war das zitat was wir damals
exklusiv aus dieser sitzung erfahren
haben und tatsächlich zwei wochen später
sitzen wir jetzt wieder hier
was merkel hilft heute das muss man auch
ganz klar sagen sind die dramatischen
zahlen zumindest was die neuinfektionen
angeht
wir sind da heute bei einem nur irgend
neuen rekordwert von fast 15.000 auf die
zahlen wollen wir auf jeden fall auch
gleich noch mal eingehen weil das war
heute morgen ja auch ein großes thema
noch aber um kurz noch bei diesem
beschluss über das gerade gesagt über
freizeitangebot wird viel diskutiert das
nächste thema ist etwas worüber ich kann
es nur meinem privaten umfeld sagen sehr
viel diskutiert wo ist die gastronomie
wenn tatsächlich nicht nur gas
geschlossen werden sondern sämtliche
restaurants und gaststätten einfach
dicht machen müssen
für die gastronomie ein wirklicher
hammer gestern am abend was man aus
diesen gesprächen gehört hat es wurde
bis tief in die nacht diskutiert in
verschiedenen runden es gab kleinere und
mit der kanzlerin es gab
ministerpräsidenten gestaffelt in
parteien und insbesondere aus der spd
hört man dass diese vorhaben was die
gastronomie angeht also sämtliche
gaststätten bars und kneipen geschlossen
ausgenommen lieferungen und ab
und auch das erinnert wieder ans
frühjahr wir erinnern uns da durfte man
dann irgendwann sein essen wieder
abholen erst nach ein paar tagen kupfer
zu zunächst fast komplett geschlossen
und dann gab es diese ausnahme also ob
das wirklich so durchgeht auch da ein
fragezeichen denn das ist natürlich ein
absoluter schlag für die gastronomie
wenn jetzt die restaurants und komplett
geschlossen werden sollen wir müssen
sagen auch das hat bild bereits vor zwei
tagen berichtet das war genau das auf
den plan
auf den wir uns bezogen haben und das
war der sogenannte lock down light light
deshalb weil schulen und kitas offen
bleiben und auch betriebe nicht
geschlossen werden dass muss man ganz
klar sagen das ist auch der unterschied
zu dem was wir im frühjahr erlebt haben
ja trotzdem das wort leid fühlt sich da
gar nicht mehr so leicht an wenn man all
diese maßnahmen sind wir wollen noch
ganz kurz sagen über versuche mir
gesprochen das war es dann aber auch
schon fast wieder an sachen die dann in
der im dienstleistungsbereich offen
bleiben auch da schwer getroffen man
darf zu keinen anderen behandlungen
eigentlich mehr gehen die man für sich
selber so zu machen würde wir sehen hier
also tattoo-studios kosmetikstudios was
noch geht sind physiotherapien weil das
ja an der gesundheit dann liegt aber
alles was man für sich selber macht
sozusagen nicht dann vielleicht das
letzte ich weiß noch nicht mal gute weil
ich finde das sehr schwer formuliert der
einzelhandel wie sieht es da aus das
wird natürlich bedeuten shoppen das ging
ja im frühling dann irgendwann auch
nicht mehr
dort soll es auflagen geben und dann
dürfen aber alle läden offen bleiben
oder wie was gibt es da schon für
details wie es im einzelhandel aussehen
wird also grundsätzlich ist es so dass
geschäfte unter hygiene auflagen
geöffnet bleiben können dürfen
aber sie müssen sicherstellen dass ich
nicht mehr als ein kunde pro 25
quadratmeter verkaufsfläche auf fällt
also ein abstandsgebot im geschäft was
ist natürlich schwierig macht gerade im
winter wir stellen uns vor
wenn es überhaupt so etwas wie
weihnachtseinkäufe geben sollte in
diesem jahr
dann stehen vielleicht die menschen
draußen schlange weil drinnen dürfen sie
sich eben nicht wirklich zusammen
aufhalten und das ist natürlich auch ein
schwerer ein schweres hemmnis für den
verkauf im einzelhandel mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste wie
johann und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren